I've got a great book recommendation for
you today I don't normally read books
like this I'm talking about the book
bringing down the house by Ben Mezrich
bringing down the house is a book about
the mit blackjack card counting team
which is quite a well-known team
actually this MIT based card counting
team that would go all over the world
and do team card counting to win money
at casinos now strictly speaking in the
United States card counting is not
illegal as long as you're not using an
electronic device or using some means to
defeat the normal odds of the game but
casinos don't like it
casinos have become increasingly
sophisticated at figuring out whether
your accounting cards and it's it's not
something that you're going to be
allowed to do if they realize that
you're doing this yeah it's just
something that's frowned upon and you
can see why the casinos wouldn't be too
into it because they're able to
calculate out how much they're going to
have to pay out yeah how much they're
going to take in so when someone's
cheating the system in their eyes they
don't like that that's taking away their
profit big casinos basically don't
distinguish between actual cheaters and
card counters they sort of consider them
to be the same thing even though they
are actually drastically different so
the book is it's a really quick read I
read it I think in two days last weekend
I learned a ton about counting cards in
team play I also then started
researching because the book is now
several years old how has Vegas changed
the rules of blackjack to prevent what
was done by the MIT card counting team
and they've done a lot of things the
tracking algorithms that can actually
detect whether even though people aren't
always playing together whether the same
people are ending up at the same tables
with frequency so they can identify team
teams of card counters more frequent
shuffles is another way to defeat the
impact of card counting there's a lot of
different ways the book is fascinating
but I want to make a recommendation if
you're going to read this book just read
the book without researching the book
first I think you will enjoy it more
that way and when you're done reading
the book again it'll take you a couple
days to read this thing then research
the book online and research the author
online I don't want to say more but
that's just my suggestion to the
audience I think you'll enjoy it more
that way
yeah that's fine by me I also wonder how
hard it is to count cards I mean do you
have to have a superior mind like
someone who goes to MIT to learn this or
a talent that anyone can pick up I would
say and you don't have to go to MIT but
I don't know that anyone can pick it up
there's a lot about that in the book
there's an interesting a couple of
chapters about that again the book is
bringing down the house by Ben Mezrich
david pakman.com slash recommendations
you can see all of my book
recommendations and documentary
recommendations and the whole thing
check it out and send me your thoughts
if you like the book dislike the book
etc we've got a great show for you today
it's Thursday but it's kind of like a
Friday show today